Bonjour!
Ceci est un nouveau format comme vous pouvez
le constater, que je vais vous présenter
dès maintenant.
Je ne sais pas si vous l'aviez remarqué,
mais il y a des filles sur Internet.
Même sur youtube.
Même qu'on fait des vidéos, et qu'on adore
ça.
Du coup, on est tellement nombreuses qu'on
s'est rassemblées et qu'on a entre autres
décidé de créer des mois thématiques,
durant lesquelles ont sort toutes une vidéo
sur un thème.
Dans la limite de notre inspiration et de
notre motivation, bien sûr.
Vous retrouverez les vidéos de toutes mes
partenaires in crime dans la description,
alors allez-les voir.
De toute façon je les partagerai aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux.
Le premier thème proposé est: le rose!
Je trouve ce thème pas mal parce qu'on peut
l'aborder sous un tas d'angles différents,
on peut en faire une approche scientifique,
genrée, chimique, sociologique, et bien sûr
historique.
Devinez quelle approche j'ai choisi!
D'un point de vue personnel, par contre, je
n'aime pas le rose.
J'ai rejeté cette couleur très tôt, au
même titre que les petits motifs de dauphins
bleu-argentés, et je ne porte presque jamais
de rose.
Mais cette couleur a une histoire passionnante.
Et nous allons la découvrir ensemble.
Donc, on va faire l'histoire des couleurs.
Avant de détailler sur le rose, on va commencer
par une petite présentation de la couleur
au MA.
La vision qu'on a aujourd'hui des couleurs
que voyaient nos ancêtres est faussée, pour
plusieurs raisons.
D'abord, en raison de l'état de conservation
des œuvres, tentures, vêtements ou constructions
qu'on conserve.
Les couleurs ont pu passer, se délaver, perdre
leur éclat...
Et on a donc du mal à s'imaginer des couleurs
vives.
Y'a qu'à voir les statues et les sculptures
dans les églises, c'est gris, c'est terne,
et ça court un risque d'être restauré avec
les pieds.
Méfiance, donc.
Ensuite, avant la diffusion de l'électricité
les couleurs n'apparaissaient pas de la même
manière que maintenant.
Quand on s'éclairait à la bougie, la chandelle
ou la lampe à huile, ça ne produisait pas
le même effet qu'avec un néon ou une simple
ampoule.
La perception des couleurs au XIIIe siècle
et de nos jour connaît donc de grandes différentes,
et pas seulement à la nuit tombée.
Comment étaient définies et utilisées les
couleurs au MA?
De nombreux auteurs ont disserté sur les
arc-en-ciels, cherchant à déterminer de
quelles couleurs ils étaient composés.
Leurs travaux nous renseignent sur ce qui
était considéré comme une couleur à l'époque:
certains décrivent les arc-en-ciels comme
composés de 3, 4 ou 5 couleurs, et Roger
Bacon en propose carrément 6: bleu, vert,
rouge, gris, rose, et blanc.
A l'époque, on parle pas encore de spectre
des couleurs et tout ça.
On retrouve également les couleurs dans les
armoiries, inventées à partir du XIIe siècle:
les couleurs des blasons, qui sont surtout
utiles lors des tournois pour différentier
les concurrents,sont au nombre de six: blanc,
jaune, rouge, bleu, noir et vert, et sont
désignées dans la langue du blason: argent,
or, gueules, azur, sable et sinople.
C'est quand même plus classe.
On remarquera que ces couleurs sont les six
couleurs de base: on ne parle pas encore
de couleurs primaires, mais il s'agit des
seules six couleurs qui n'ont pas de référent
dans la nature.
Elles sont abstraites, contrairement à l'orange
qui vient de ceci, au marron, au rose, etc...
Michel Pastoureau, qui a beaucoup travaillé
sur l'histoire des couleurs, les qualifie
alors de «demi-couleurs».
Les couleurs sont aussi utilisées dans les
teintures, des vêtements mais pas seulement;
tous les vêtements sont teints au MA, pas
uniquement ceux des riches, mais les vêtements
de riches ont des couleurs plus vives, du
fait de la meilleure qualité des tissus et
des teintures, plus éclatantes, alors que
les pauvres ont des vêtements plus délavés.
C'est la seule différence en terme de couleurs,
puisqu'il n'existe pas de couleur réservée
aux riches ou de couleur réservée aux pauvres.
Dans les cours princières ont ne teinte pas
uniquement les vêtements mais un peu tout
ce qui passe par la main, comme les aliments
ou les pelages et plumages des animaux.
Comme quoi teindre son caniche en rose ne
date pas d'hier.
Pour désigner les couleurs qui ne sont pas
les six couleurs de base, ou pour apporter
des nuances selon les tons de ces couleurs,
en se référant souvent à des éléments
naturels pour les désigner: on trouve dans
les archives des «bleu nuage», «safran»,
«rouge grenade», «couleur de plomb»
«couleur de cristal de bambou» ou «comme
le cou d'une colombe» pour faire référence
à une couleur iridescente.
Tout ça fait un peu penser à Peau d'Ane
et à ses robes couleur de lune.
Maintenant, on va s'intéresser au rose.
Comme vous l'aurez compris le rose n'est pas
une des couleurs de base au Moyen-Âge, et
n'est d'ailleurs pas appelé rose avant un
moment.
Même au XIXe siècle, les théoriciens de
la couleur refusent de lui donner le statut
de véritable couleur: pour eux ce n'est
qu'un mélange de blanc et de rouge, synthétique
et un peu vulgaire.
C'est pas moi qui l'ai dit!
Son nom vient de la fleur éponyme, on parle
donc de «couleur de rose» avant de commencer
à utiliser le terme «rose» à la fin
du Moyen-Âge.
On parle aussi parfois de «rouge clair»
ou «rouge blanc»: il n'est considéré
que comme une nuance du rouge, un rouge clair
assez peu apprécié parce qu'on ne savait
pas fabriquer de beau ton de rose au MA.
Le rose est également appelé «incarnat»
au MA, c'est sous ce nom qu'on le retrouve
souvent dans les recettes de teinturerie par
exemple.
Le rose est ainsi obtenu par teinture, grâce
à différents procédés: on peut obtenir
du rosat à partir de kermès, de l'incarnat
ou de la couleur «fleur de pêcher»
à partir de garance, de la «couleur de
rose sèche» à la garance et au bois de
brésil.
La teinture au bois de brésil est celle qui
est ensuite privilégiée, à la fin du MA
lorsque le rose devient davantage utilisé:
il s'agit d'un bois importé de Sumatra, et
donc cher.
C'est pour ça que le rose est peu diffusé.
A partir du XVIe siècle on découvre un bois
très voisin en Amérique du Sud, ce qui coûte
moins cher à importer: c'est grâce à
ça que le rose se diffuse enfin au XVIe-XVIIe
siècle.
C'est aussi grâce à la découverte d'un
bois proche du bois de Brésil au Brésil
que le Brésil s'appelle Brésil.
Vous suivez?
L'usage du terme «rose» devient courant
au XVIIe siècle, quand cette teinte devient
plus fréquente dans les vêtements ou l'art.
Il existe des tas de nuances de rose, que
je vais vous citer parce qu'elles ont de jolis
noms: les roses clairs peuvent s'appeler
bisque, carnation, carné, chair, coquille
d’œuf, cuisse de nymphe, pêche, rose dragée,
vieux rose.
Pour les roses foncés on a le capucine, cuisse
de nymphe émue, rose fuchsia, grenadine,
héliotrope, nacarat, pelure d'oignon, rose
balais, rose bonbon, rose thé, rose vif,
fraise, fraise écrasée, framboise, lilas,
saumon.
Le rose est souvent considéré comme une
couleur «féminine», car depuis le XVIe
siècle, en France du moins, le rouge est
une couleur féminine.
Jusqu'au XIXe siècle, les mariées portent
des robes rouges.
Auparavant, il est intéressant de noter que
c'était...
Tout l'inverse d'aujourd'hui.
Le rouge était la couleur du sang, associée
au dieu Mars de la guerre, c'était donc une
couleur d'homme plein de testostérones.
Au contraire, le bleu était la couleur de
la Vierge Marie: on ne pouvait pas faire
plus féminin.
Jusqu'au XVIe siècle c'est donc le bleu qui
est une couleur féminine, et pas le rouge
ni le rose.
Au fil du temps le rose devient donc une couleur
associée aux femmes, mais parfois aussi à
l'enfance, au bonheur, au romantisme, voire
à l'érotisme avec le téléphone rose par
exemple.
Voilà pour moi, j'espère que cette petite
vidéo vous a plu.
J'ai choisi de faire un historique du rose,
ce qui n'était pas si évident parce qu'il
y a assez peu de travaux sur cette couleur.
Le grand historien de la couleur est Michel
Pastoureau, qui a écrit sur le noir, le bleu,
le rouge, le vert...
Mais pas le rose évidemment.
Si l'histoire des couleurs vous intéresse,
ses travaux sont vraiment très intéressants
et agréables à lire.
Je laisse maintenant la parole aux autres
filles dont vous retrouverez les vidéos dans
la description à mesure qu'elles sortiront.
Et je les partagerai de toute manière sur
les réseaux sociaux.
J'espère que vous avez aimé notre idée
et que vous serez toujours là pour le thème
2!
La prochaine vidéo sera à nouveau du Chroniques
de Prof, alors à bientôt!